hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of Thrones if you'd like to
watch the full video head over to
youtube.com slash gamespot so I mean
first up we've got mirror and bran wise
but mais mirror saying I'm so sorry um
see I didn't even think it sounded like
her voice honest I thought it might be a
flashback voice oh god what if it's
liana in the Tower of joy that's why I'm
so sorry Ned yeah promise me Ned hmm I
could be interesting but also it seems
like in one of these flashes that one of
these I don't know you think they're a
white Walker you think that they are
white could that be a mysterious other
this could be cold hands they don't swap
that round yeah looks like a race yeah
cuz I mean she can't Mira cannot carry
branna by herself don't worry they do
not have much of a head start yeah um
which makes me wonder if they're
switching the story lands around a
little bit yeah we also see Sam taking
Gilly home um and you can see Samwell
Tarly dad who doesn't look very nice
that look that his dad gives him when he
sees his new paramour yeah I am
genuinely sure that my mother has given
me that look I brought home a girlfriend
and you've had to be ex is my bastard
son and she's like day for be done did
you find it off the wall kara I mouse oh
but yes those interested to see if he'll
accept Gilly it's that you hear that
Gilley says you didn't you didn't tell
him I'm a wildling did you too mmm and
then we get to see that's gonna be a
King's Landing episode we didn't get
anything from King's Landing this
episode also no dawn for four or five
four episodes are yeah it's happily yeah
ticking along by itself so stubborn and
Dawn so this could be Marjorie's walk
that's gonna get interrupted by the
Tyrell forces so we see them around the
scepter bail or Cersei let let me show
them what we do to our enemies so I the
enemies here could be the faith everyone
could be really the last I Royals goes
everywhere unofficial motto we hate
everyone you also get a brief flash of
with the high Sparrow what's he doing
this time just ripping his backbone out
uh and that's we did last episode just
keeps doing it then we got Dario and
Daenerys note that jaw is not this he's
clearly wandered off somewhere to find a
cure he's been ordered to find his cure
um generis is like I'll take what's mine
oh he's like he's giving him more
goddamn titles he's like ordinary
reconquer mm-hmm her business cards
about that long at this point um so I
mean that must me you know she goes back
to marine mmm tries to but I mean the
thing is Tyrion and Varys have worked up
a damn piece yeah well wandering in here
with a damn army I'm not sure their
piece is as good as they think is they
say it's fragile anyway but I mean they
said oh we've managed to avoid Civil War
but I think they're gonna cause a civil
war mmm dragons are gonna have to come
out soon I'm getting I'm getting antsy
and wait the drums
you